LCS fans have been holding their breath
after Riot and the Players Association
clashed over the future of the tier 2
scene which led to an impending player
walkout the League's start was suspended
for two weeks last night the two parties
came to an agreement the LCS summer
split will begin next week but who
really came out on top in these
negotiations
all right so just to refresh your
memories last week Riot decided to
suspend the LCS summer splits June 1st
start date in order to have negotiations
with the Players Association over their
plans to conduct a walkout the players
protest was in response to riot at the
request of LCS teams removing the
Mandate for orgs to field an academy
team in the NaCl North America's tier 2
league they said this was done to allow
for more financial flexibility for teams
or in other words it wasn't cost
effective we saw a number of Orcs
dropping their Academy teams and even
the few that didn't made it clear they
felt the league was not fit for purpose
as a sustainable path to the pro level
for players The Players Association who
act as an organized voice for players to
negotiate and talk to riots laid out how
they felt these changes would destroy
the NaCl and see up to 70 players
coaches and managers lose their jobs
they also contested the claim that the
LCS teams cannot afford to cover the
salary costs of an academy roster but
with no signs a reversal from riots
things stepped up on May 23rd The
Players Association issued a list of
requests of riot in order to avoid a
walkout of LCS players during the first
week of the split we'll come back to
these later with no agreement from Riot
on those demands the players voted on
whether to conduct a walkout on May 29th
the players later known to be over 90
percent of them voted yes to the walkout
The Players Association called on Bryant
to have an open conversation with them
to avert it in an attempt to circumvent
the walkout altogether Riot responded by
allowing LCS orgs who are contractually
obliged to field a team the ability to
sign players post roster lock they even
remove the rank requirement and said
players could play remotely The Players
Association warned that any player that
tried to fill those empty spots would be
seen as a scab who's putting all players
Futures at risk with just two days to go
before the plan June first start of the
LCS Riot finally spoke out they
contested all of the players
association's request but conceded that
allowing the LCS to continue without the
majority of regular players was against
their values they announced they would
be suspending the LCS for two weeks for
productive dialogue but warned any
further delay would result in the
cancellation of the entire split with na
teams being excluded from Worlds as a
result that was only last week but it's
felt like an eternity for LCS fans who
have been waiting to see whether the LCS
will implode and not return until 2024
or at worst maybe ever last night though
Riot and the Players Association
announced they had come to an agreement
and the LCS will start on Wednesday June
14th a quote from Global head of LoL
Esports Naz alataraha read the laying
summer split was not a decision we took
lightly But ultimately the dialogue
between the league the lcspa and teams
provided the space to realign on shared
goals for the future of the LCS and NaCl
building for the long-term
sustainability and success of the LCS
ecosystem is the win condition for us
all we want to thank the LCS fans
players and teams for their patients
during this period and look forward to
seeing players back on the LCS stage
next week Riot then broke down what had
come of those discussions but just
before we look at that let's remind
ourselves of the players association's
initial requests they'd asked for
promotion and relegation between the LCS
and NaCl three hundred thousand dollars
for NaCl teams every year allowing LCS
orgs to partner with Affiliates for cost
sharing guaranteeing LCS minimum
contracts for the following year for LCS
summer winners and instituting a rule to
allow released NaCl rosters first
priority to maintain their slots if a
team's majority continued to compete
together in yesterday's announcement
Riot announced a new NaCl model that
shares revenue between the tournament
operator and teams improvements to the
nacl's governance model including a team
participating agreement and vetting of
participating orgs a minimum 30-day
notice and several requirement for
players earning up to 1.5 times the
league minimum salary and a minimum
two-week termination notice for
non-resident LCS players the creation of
a working group between teams and the
Players Association for optimizing scrim
schedules the reinforcement of
healthcare insurance requirements for
international LCS players and of working
procedures between the LCS The Players
Association and teams when discussing
improvements in the league okay that was
a lot of words so did the Players
Association actually get what they set
out for in their statement they
acknowledge what they called concessions
from Riot they said Riot's announcement
did fall short of their goals but what
they had agreed to was a series of
important changes and that Riot had
committed to meaningful collaboration
with the PA before making future
decisions they said the concessions did
not return the NaCl fully or provide
restoration for players who have already
lost their jobs or suffered due to the
changes but asserted that they've
accomplished a guarantee by right to
support or the new NaCl format increased
financial support for it introduce
accountability measures and bring in
protections for their lowest earning
members their summary of the agreed
terms also differed slightly from riots
they stated that talks are continuing on
unresolved issues so we may still see
some more concessions from riot in the
future in addition they mentioned that
50 of all future NaCl sponsorship will
now be shared by NaCl teams and also
that the parties would be signing a
memorandum of understanding that mou as
it's called seems to be what Riot was
referring to in their statement as a
refinement of working procedures and
it's pretty crucial to all of this the
signing of an mou is a public
acknowledged from Riot that they at
least on the surface are taking
seriously the desire of The Players
Association to be involved in any future
policy changes when I spoke to the head
of the Players Association Philip Aram
last week he told me that that lack of
involvement in the decision-making
process was what led to the war count
vote so now if Riot does intend to
include them more in their
decision-making process then yeah you
could call that a win for the Players
Association but critically an mou is not
legally binding right would undoubtedly
face backlash and protest if they were
seen to be going back on it but they
can't be held to it by law as for the
rest of what the player's Association
has asked for none of it seems to have
been accepted wholesale by riots they're
not introducing promotion and relegation
between the NaCl and LCS as they feel
it's unfair to the orgs that pay 10
million for their permanent spot in the
franchise League they're also not
guaranteeing minimum contracts for LCS
summer winners and not introducing that
three-fifth roster continuity rule
however the concessions from Riot are at
the very least of a similar nature to
the requests of them we're seeing the
introduction of contract termination for
players minimum standard agreements and
increased funding for the league and
that is all in line with the players
association's desire for safeguards
assurances and protection for their play
players this is undoubtedly a net
positive how impactful will they really
be we'll have to see are they exactly
what the pa asked for from Riot no and
they've been the first to admit that but
that likely was never their realistic
expectation to begin with this is
bargaining 101 I'm sure the Players
Association would have been just as
surprised as all of us if Riot agreed to
every request of them down to the letter
but they've negotiated compromises in
areas that mean the most to them and
most importantly they've shown everyone
that at the very least they can have a
unified voice that brings Riot to the
table for discussion now the question is
of course can they really do anything
more than that the threat of a walkout
got them this far but they can't rely on
repeatedly pulling that out if their
relationship with Riot deteriorates
again earlier this week doublelift got
some backlash for saying that although
he did vote for the walkout he would
still play if it really came down to it
with some accusing him of undermining
the negotiations it's only like turning
point in the negotiation is a threat of
like Exterminating the LCS for summer
split and canceling it then I don't even
like I wouldn't even want there to be
negotiations because that's so crazy
like 50 people will literally not have a
job
all the LCS orgs are gonna have like
super devalued and the coaches are yeah
everyone like we just will not have a
job that's crazy like I'm I don't think
anyone wants that to be uh The Leverage
not whether or not you agree with double
lift he's touched on something at the
very core of this that the power still
ultimately lies with Riot they own the
league that these players livelihoods
depend upon that is the nature of a
franchise League years ago some warned
about this power imbalance coming back
to bite players in the ass if Riot ever
ran the league in a way the players
disagreed with and we're seeing that
play out in real time here the Players
Association have assigned understanding
that they'll have more of the seats at
riots decision-making table going
forward they also have concessions that
seek to address areas of concern for
them but is it all enough is this a
positive step in the right direction for
players and the tier 2 scene or just a
token gesture of cooperation from a
company that still very much holds all
the cards here perhaps it's something in
between Queen all we know for sure is
that the LCS will begin on Wednesday
June 14th with an extra day during the
initial weeks to get back on schedule
despite all these Grand statements and
resolutions this story doesn't really
feel over let me know what you think
foreign
[Music]